let's go to five headlines
[Music]
the rioters in portland are still at it
of course let's check in and
see how that's going on
[Applause]
oh
you know you see videos like that and
it it
we should remember that yes
these are violent domestic terrorists
who should all be arrested and sent to
prison
um but also
these are scrawny weak pathetic
whims and that's and that's the thing
that always jumps out at you when you
see these videos
there's a reason why they operate in
packs in groups
and that's how they attack people that's
how they do everything because
one-on-one these are just
utterly pathetic and unimpressive people
and that's i think that's
a big reason why they're doing what
they're doing
um it's it's a way of feeling i mean a
lot of these people probably were
bullied in school
um and have just been treated as uh
pathetic and unimpressive because they
are their whole lives and now they're
finding a way to
finally an outlet where they can feel
strong and powerful they put on the
black costume and the mask and they go
out and smash stuff
uh but they can't even successfully
smash glass with a with a
you know with a fire extinguisher um
because you know probably the guy you're
seeing there probably bench presses
47 pounds or something if that um so
that's
and that's the balance i always want to
strike when we talk about
antifa and the writers that on one hand
they do represent a very real threat
but i don't i also don't want to make
the mistake
of portraying them as if they
individually
are tough and scary people because they
aren't at all
but you put a group of any i mean you
put doesn't matter how weak and
and pitiful you are as a person if you
get together in a group of 100 people or
more
and you've got weapons and you're
setting fires yeah um you're gonna be
dangerous
okay let's go to number two here report
from
the daily wire says the wife of abc's
good morning host
george stephanopoulos revealed she's
perfectly willing
to teach her teenage daughters about sex
by watching porn with them
ali wentworth whose daughters are 15 and
17 told the dissenters podcast that porn
would be educational for them because
she could explain that porn is
performative rather than realistic
according to yahoo news wentworth said
in porn women have been conditioned to
look and act a certain way
they are performing and it's dangerous
to have boys see this as something women
want
you can't stop them so i would watch it
with them i would look at the porn with
them
that one time like they're performing
and then she goes on i have an issue
with how we are raising
this generation of children because we
grew up without social media for us our
children
us as parents are guinea pigs you know
what i mean i don't know what to say
about don't use your phone use your
phone and i start learning as i went
when i would see other people's
daughters and how sexualized they were
on social media
and i became very passionate about the
idea that we went to we want to regulate
social media
we need to chart these waters for our
kids so i started doing these panels on
the social media
and its effects and my feeling was this
was a very dangerous thing
i see it with other kids our suicide
rate too has doubled i see the bad
effects i think there are good effects
too
i mean this i'm just reading a
transcript right now this doesn't make
any sense it sounds like
was she drunk or something that that
wouldn't make it much better that would
make it a little bit better if she was
drunk while when she did i have no idea
if she was or not um
but this is largely incoherent i mean we
we do find that she's worried about
people's daughters being sexualized she
seems to be worried
from what i can decipher about the
effects of social media and her way of
responding to that is to watch hardcore
pornography with her daughters
including her 15 year old daughter
nothing matters i mean really
no matter how old the daughter is that's
just creepy and disgusting and weird
um to put up mildly so there's george
stephanopoulos
wife number three reading um
again from the daily wire says
st louis uh circuit attorney kim gardner
a democrat announced on monday that
she's charging the saint louis couple
defended their private property using
firearms last month
with felony unlawful use of a weapon the
couple also reportedly faces
a fourth degree misdemeanor assault
charge
the st louis dispatch reported mark and
patricia mccloskey each are facing a
single felony count of unlawful use of a
weapon
exhibiting charging documents say he
pointed an ar-15 rifle of protesters and
she wielded a semi-automatic handgun
placing those protesters in fear of
injury
so just to reiterate on this case
because this is
obviously an outrageous miscarriage of
justice and and the governors are has
already said
that he would pardon if there were
charges brought he would pardon these
two
uh american citizens who were only
defending their own property
and i'm glad to hear that but the fact
that charges were pressed at all
uh is as i said outrageous
they're standing on their own property
holding firearms that is their second
amendment right this is a direct
attack on the second amendment and it's
not as though despite what we hear from
the media
it's not as though they had no reason to
think
that these supposed peaceful protesters
might be violent
this is how dumb the media thinks we are
this is how dumb a lot of people
actually are
that they're you know they're they're
portraying the mccloskeys as these
gun-toting lunatics and say well what
why would they think that they were at
any risk i mean these were peaceful as
if we haven't all been watching the news
for two
for two months and seeing cities across
the country buildings being burned
random people assaulted let's pretend we
haven't seen that
no well except for all of that
there's just no reason at all to think
that for them to have thought that they
were in any physical
danger at all number four going back to
the portland riots for a moment here's
another interesting recent phenomenon at
these riots
first let's just watch this footage here
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
hey
so what you're seeing there are the moms
the antifa moms have shown up
and they are forming a human
chain a shield to shield their precious
children
as their precious children commit
felonies such as trying to set a federal
building on fire
so commit serious serious dangerous
felonies the moms have shown up to
help them a to bed them in their crimes
so
to to those of us who had been
theorizing
that one of the reasons why antifa
exists is because of horrible parenting
now we have confirmation for that theory
if there was any doubt at all
the the pair the terrible neglectful
awful parents have actually showed up
to advertise to all but announce oh yeah
yeah we're horrible well look at us look
how horrible we are
they're on parade they are parading
their awful parenting for all of us to
see
so glad to glad to get that confirmation
that feels that feels good at least
number five and now the ap um the ap is
the latest to come out and say that the
the word black um should be capitalized
but not white and we we've seen this
more and more recently but i want you to
listen to here's the ap
explaining why um there is this
dichotomy where we capitalize one and
not the other says
the ap said this is according to an ap
report the ap said white people in
general have much less shared history
and culture
and don't have the experience of being
discriminated against because of skin
color
we agree that this is now john
danishowski the ap's vice president for
standards said in a memo we agree that
white people's skin color plays into
systemic inequalities and justices
and we want our journalism to robustly
explore these problems but capitalizing
the term white
as is done by white supremacists risks
subtly conveying legitimacy
uh to such beliefs okay
this is obviously nonsense i mean
even if i were to agree that white
people are never discriminated against
because of their skin color
which of course is not true
talk about systemic racism okay
the only explicit
out in the open example of actual
systemic
racism like it's a policy that we're
going to discriminate against
certain races the only one that the only
example anyone could come up with
is affirmative action and that's that is
discrimination against white people so
but even if i were to agree with that um
you know white people don't have the
experience of being discriminated
against
what does that have to do with grammar
what does it have to do with punctuation
so we're you're gonna uh uh or
capitalization rather
so you you capitalize the first letter
in the word black because they're
discriminated against but not but
not white because they're not what
relation is there between those two
things
total nonsense
but this is the left turning grammar
into as and this is not the first
example of it obviously but this is
grammar being politicized this is a gram
even grammar now
is an ideological concern
and so even when you're deciding what
letters to capitalize
it's you're not you're not making that
determination based on any grammatical
rule
you're making it based on ideological
doctrine
and that's what we see once again thank
you for tuning in to the daily wire one
of the fastest growing conservative
media outlets in the entire country if
you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content